all right well a lot of elements in this
movie that were
from the first movie so shorter answer
is watch coming to america the first one
it's enjoyable and it's a better version
of this movie but if you want to stick
around for a review
and watch me ramble for a few minutes
well here we go
[Music]
coming to america so coming to america
is a sequel to coming to america i'm not
going to do that the whole time i guess
calling it coming to america too would
probably be easiest so when coming to
america too it's been decades since the
events of coming to america eddie
murphy's character akeem he learns he
has a bastard
in america so he goes and gets him and
brings him back because he's gonna be
the heir to the throne and talking about
what i
liked in this movie hands down my
favorite part of this movie was wesley
snipes he's this military leader this
dictator of this neighboring land which
is great that you start seeing
other places you're like i always
thought like what's the land around this
but like who were the neighboring
countries the wesley snipes i thought
crushed it but
that's where you start falling into the
fact it's like i've seen this plot
before because this new prince is going
to be arranged to marry the daughter of
this
leader this dictator and he doesn't want
to and he falls in love with someone
else
seems pretty familiar i don't want to do
that thing where you compare it to the
original movie and it falls
short but it's hard it's hard to not do
that when this movie
makes a conscious effort to take some of
the same beats plot-wise anyway
the most important thing is this is a
comedy most important thing in a comedy
is to be funny
make me laugh the movie didn't really
make me laugh and yeah granted comedy's
different now you look at the original
coming to america here i go
i'm comparing again but if you look at
it a lot of the comedy was
wrapped up in the absurdity of the
wealth of this family this royalty when
they're at the airport and they're
dressed
clearly like royalty and eddie murphy's
like remember
we have to blend in in our city hall's
like i won't say a thing they're just
they look everyone's turning like who's
the royalty it relied on
a joke and a beat for the audience to
process take it in and laugh nowadays
what i see a lot in comedy and
in coming to america too it's joke and
then quippy comeback joke
or reference and there you go it's like
the characters are trying to make the
characters in the movie laugh not the
audience but it's important to include
the audience in that and that's the
problem because the original coming to
america
i laugh in it's funny to me coming to
america too
didn't laugh it's like comedies and
movies in general let's face it
they think you're dumb you know like
hollywood thinks people are stupid but i
just can't stand it when jokes are so on
the nose explained like there's one
scenario it's not really a joke
it's actually a pretty relevant phrase
eddie murphy's character he's king now
so he
starts feeling the weight of these
decisions you know it's really tough for
him
and the phrase heavy is the head that
wears the crown is thrown out as heavy
as the head that wears the crown heavy
lies the crown
however you want to say it it's a good
phrase you know but we know what it
means just from the phrase it's like oh
it's not talking about the weight of the
crown maybe
that limbic response is to see it that
way and you're like oh no it's talking
about the responsibility
we just we know that because the phrase
is layered enough and accessible enough
for us to know that this movie explains
it you know it's like oh heavy's the
head that wears the crown i'm starting
to realize that more and more yeah it's
not just the weight of the crown just
the responsibility that comes with it
it's like thanks for explaining it
because we're dumb
it's just one example but when i saw
that i was like okay that's the last
draw and that's my example
i'm going to throw into here and like
you know creepy preacher guy creepy
preacher guy who is in
the first coming to america's character
is back because you know
sequel but they call him the sexist
preacher i think
three different times in here i mean
granted he is the creepy sexist preacher
we knew that from the first movie he was
one of those guys oh i got the calling
he's like no you didn't
you're just trying to get some of that
great christian ass that's your thing
that's what you're doing we all knew he
was a creepy televangelist guy
the audience can get there by themselves
but no they have to call him the sexist
preacher like oh the guy's sexy did you
get that audience
because he is this is my point of saying
all of this is that
subtlety and nuance makes comedy but
subtlety and nuance isn't in comedy
anymore and i think the reason
is because if you don't say that like if
you don't blatantly call
the creepy sexist preacher guy a sexist
preacher then somehow
some corner of twitter is gonna be like
oh they didn't call him out on it
in the movie so obviously they're
advocating for it that's problematic and
then all right
start the canceling so that's why you
have to just explain all your jokes in
movies otherwise people are gonna get
the wrong idea and that's why
comedy is what's the word dying
anyhow coming to america too it's a
comedy and i didn't really laugh at it
this movie's aware of it though it knows
what it is because they even make the
joke
in this movie it's a very meta moment
where they talk about sequels to 30 year
old movies that no one asked for that
aren't good but in the end it doesn't
matter because i'm not gonna remember
this movie in t minus one day yep
already forgot it's just like the purity
and heart of the original it's your
basic
sequel to a 30 year old movie this is
how it usually goes down
all right so coming to america have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you